question to you guys going off this then
but it's a bit less depressing has there
been any shows or any anime in your in
your history that has like affected you
in any way not just like not just like
in the negative aspect obviously or just
rethinking life but just like black but
look I think me like the one as much as
I hate to use the word change my life
for me was like and this is gonna sound
cliche as [ __ ] but Clannad was one I
totally understand when I laughed it
comes from I'm sure there was a handful
of people who laughed at the same time
right because it's so cliche now to say
that climate change I play when I watch
that like all the way through it like
straight up because that was off his
story [ __ ] me out that was the first
time that I like in not just in anime
but in any piece of media then I just
[ __ ] broke down yeah yeah because
especially that second half of Clannad
after story it was just the most brutal
play of those two the longest build-up
right and just I don't think I'll be
able to that's again like going back
like million topics that's another show
I don't think I'll be able to watch
again yeah just because again I'm not in
that headspace and it's just something
it's not just like the fact that it was
just a sad anime but I think it's just
the fact that again you've been kind of
following these characters lives all the
way through where like where as like
most you know visual novels or like
romance stories would end with the
couple getting together yeah my dad took
that one step further and showed you as
the title says the after story right of
like what happens and I think just
seeing that made these characters even
more relatable to me and that was the
first time where I was like you know
what family family is cool man like
family's [ __ ] door like before that
family was just like a Christian man
because like you know the concept of
like family was just very much like
everybody else was like yeah of course
family's cool like yeah everyone wants a
family
but like Clannad was that one show that
really dug into like just how important
family is and I think that like I mean
as weird as it is to say after I watch
Clannad I became way close
my family and I think that's like a be
pretty wholesome that it is wholesome
and I'm like and that like really
changed my life I feel really bad now
cuz you're talking about how can I
change your life I couldn't [ __ ]
finish the first thing yeah cleaner than
half and after yeah I think the whole
time when I thought in cloud I'm like
when's it gonna get good I am don't
[ __ ] sing that dango song I dare you
to sing that song cuz like I remember
watching the first eight episodes and
I'm just like this this is trying really
hard this is this is priority bog boring
yes but that's the problem right is that
like the thing was the first season of
Clan I never say to people hey you
should watch the first season of
Kleinert
yeah because I know that on the grand
scale of things the first season [ __ ]
appreciate the second season that's the
problem you can't jump in the after
story without having experienced these
characters yeah and it is important
because a lot of these characters do
make it a very significant impact in
after story but I guess you know it's
it's really hard I guess especially now
like baby back then you could make so
much 25 episodes yeah yeah [ __ ] to
data can pay off but now you can't do
that I just don't think you can
recommend dirty right because like the
the story structure and the joke
structures that help in it's just so
overdone now that laying down it just
seems like an aged version of everything
that you can see today but back when
Clannad first came out like 2009 I
believe yeah it's about 2007 mm I
watched how are you Susan ER the first
season and I remember thinking like this
is just like shittier is cool dynamic
which is garbage
do you just watch every high school
anime and just like yeah it's in high
school yeah it's the same I like to
compare the high school animes since you
won't like dynamics they look going on
and see what I'm all then all the
uniform is difference in their on before
was a model school okay